Whoever has that kid wins the
war what do you want sweetie for robots
to be
free hey GTH how are you I'm good thank
you how are you I doing fantastic Gareth
I just got to tell you this movie is
probably one of my favorite movies of
2023 absolutely amazing um really really
fantastic film let's kind of dive into
this little bit because I mean in the
era of big IP films how hard is it to
make a film that is original in this day
and age the hardest thing is not making
the movie the hardest thing is getting a
studio to give you the money to make the
movie um like as we all
know franchises and sequels and IP and
whatever name you want to give it is
kind of kind of taken over cinema at the
moment and I grew up obviously in the '
80s and early '90s where every movie it
felt like every week was a new sci-fi or
fantasy
Blockbuster and and so I was trying to
recreate that feeling I was trying to go
back to those movies that I loved
growing up with and put them all into a
part and stir it and pull out something
hopefully that felt a bit you know
unique and new no def and it it shows
it's really refreshing and something to
me that uh stood out amongst many films
over the last few years and just kind of
going back a little bit in terms of your
film history with Rogue one with Star
Wars Rogue one which some may say is one
of the better of the new Star Wars films
out there what did you what were some of
the lessons that you learned from robe
one that you brought it to the the
Creator there's lots of lessons you can
learn from any film making process I
think I think things that we we felt
were successful was um
so we shot in the moldes we shot in real
beaches you know obviously it was
horrific to have to go to the mes uh for
a film shoot but we took one for the
team and and so this whole the whole end
sequence uh on Scarff at the end of the
movie was was some of that was shot on
the real beaches of in in you know the
Indian Ocean uh we went to W rum you
know in Jordan and we even shot in um
real train stations and then digitally
changed them afterwards
and and they were really that that stuff
really excited me and I think is you
know what kept the film grounded to some
extent and so I wanted to do a whole
movie that way so with the Creator it
was like I don't want to film in the
studios I don't want to build sets you
know what I mean like we want to go to
real locations so we went to eight
different countries around the world we
shot in 80 locations we traveled 10,000
miles to the Himalayas to volcanoes
temple ruins in Cambodia and floating
villages all sorts and and then added
the science fiction on top so we have
this really like Rich canvas you know as
a starting point which I think makes the
film feel like very different to a
normal blobster it does you know and
something that I really I realize about
your films too is that I'm by the way
I'm in America living in Singapore so
I'm talking to you from Asia right now
about 4:50 a.m. in the morning um but
your love affair for the Asian culture
the countries where did that come from
my assumption is that everyone has that
feeling so um I think I thought it was
like I feel like it's the default
setting of most people but if it isn't
if it came from somewhere I was very
lucky when I was about
12 um my parents wanted to go on a
really nice holiday like they saved up
I'm like we want to go somewhere really
special and we went we ended up going to
Hong Kong and uh Thailand and we sort of
went to changai the jungles and Bangkok
and the beaches and stuff and you know I
was at that perfect age I was reading
science fiction and something about that
that holiday that that experience got
really embedded in my mind and I was my
dad had a video camera he bought a video
camera and I just took it the entire
holiday I filmed the whole trip and so I
was filming it all through this lens and
and I always like I think it just got
burnt into my retina those visuals it
was so fascinating was like the closest
thing I could have had as a kid to going
to another planet like I didn't
understand anything I was seeing and and
and then you know uh as an adult I've
just always I can't help it I always go
back and there's something beautiful
about taking
Asian art and and kind of blending it
with Western Art and vice versa like
when you go around places like Japan you
see English and American and Western
influences on on their pop culture but
not fully just a little bit and they've
done their own twist on it and and I
kind of really enjoy it cuz I know that
must be like what it looks like to them
when they come here and so there's this
like bouncing back and forth of ideas
that with a little different spin each
time that I I think really healthy no it
is and it's really um it's ey opening to
see it especially because being out here
for 16 years myself and living here and
see it through your eyes it's refreshing
from some filmmakers just don't get it
you know what I mean the nuances of the
culture and speaking of which because
there is a love for not only just the
visuals but the people themselves and
how they integrate of course in this D
develop that kind of divides between the
west and New Asia what
was what were some of the challenges
that you faced sort of try to to to try
to create that I think just I mean we
shot during the pandemic or just a tail
end of the pandemic so my biggest fear
when we went to film this is cuz I think
one of the most important things in the
movie were people's faces you know and
seeing kids running around in the
streets and
like just the realism of being in these
amazing locations and I didn't want this
Hollywood movie to come and like block
all that off and then add to that the
pandemic with everyone wearing a mask I
was really paranoid that it wasn't we
weren't going to get that on screen and
we came just at the right time when
everyone was allowed to take their masks
off but yet there was no tourists there
properly and so we sort of had the
freedom like it was kind of worked
totally in our favor where we we went
around and there was there was no other
could you know for a long time didn't
see any other westerners and we were
just shooting all these Villages who
were really happy to see us cuz we were
like the first tourists back in and so
everyone was very welcoming and um it
was a beautiful thing and everyone
wanted to be in the movie um it was it
was surreal so we got very lucky in a
way we used like the negative as the
positive to some extent fantastic and
for the performances of the actors
especially like John David Washington
and meline Yaba Wes I mean they're so
good in this was being around Asia did
it sort of change their performances
from their auditions or from when you
first met them in America and then you
brought them here yeah I think so I mean
they're amazing actors they it would
have been stunning no matter what but I
know John David really wanted to he's
not a method actor in the sense that you
know you can talk to him he's so down to
earth and and such a sweet guy in
between takes but I think he was quite
determined to have the kind of
experience that Joshua in the movie has
he's the character he was playing and
have this sort of
transformative uh journey and he's every
time we weren't filming he was off
wandering around like just having his
own little moment you know and and
what's funny is mlin became his best
friend so she would run after him and
like interrupt these like you know
beautiful things he was experiencing and
like talk to him about some toy she'
just got or something and it was it was
really like kind of hilarious to watch
in a weird way will you help a fi like
this where you have so much you have so
much going on to it you have heart you
have story yet there's Side by there
spectacle how do you as a director find
the balance to keep that story going and
motivating him in such a more a very
emotional way the way I probably work is
I grabbed everything so I shot loads and
loads and loads and the first cut of
that movie was 5 hours nearly 5 hours
then it becomes a game of like removing
things and obviously the most important
thing is is that you care about the
characters you you feel like emotionally
what they're going through and so um and
that becomes less about what I think and
a lot more about what the audience
thinks and so you show people and they
tell you what's working what isn't
working and you you Tinker a bit more
you show other people again and and
that's kind of what post- production is
for about 6 months you keep showing
people and you keep tweaking it and
until you feel like I think we're there
I think we've got it just the right
level of everything and so you never get
it right the first time but it but based
on feedback you kind of you get there in
the end hopefully all right well G
that's it for me for today thank you so
much and thank you for making this film
and I hope you're nominated I really do
this is really one of the better films
I've seen up 2023 and thank you for it
appreciate it thank you so much thanks
very kind thank you